this presentation is delivered by the
stanford center for professional
development
so uh thank you very much for for coming
in today even though it's the
uh first week of the year and uh uh you
may have been tempted to expand the
vacation a little bit longer
um it's uh very nice to to be back here
and
uh tell you a little bit more about what
we've been up to over the last few years
and so i was thinking long and hard
about how to call this talk and how to
explain what we're doing
and i still did not come up with uh as
brilliant
an idea as as andy did with the control
bits uh being
one-to-one with the gates versus
instructions which are small
controlling an entire chip but i think
that will give me personally
quite something to think about in in the
next few weeks
instead uh what i'm going to focus on
is the vertical versus horizontal way
of doing computation in a horizontal way
you think of somebody making
a microprocessor somebody else making an
operating system
somebody else thinking about
the software layers on top and each one
of these has to work
for all applications right and
we are taking a vertical approach to
this where we say
let's look at what we can do across the
entire stack of things
and so in order to do that we need to
look at things
slightly rotated so so if you look at it
from a different perspective
you sometimes see things that other
people don't see
and have opportunities to do
optimizations and
to match what you're doing to what you
would like to have as a result
in a slightly different way
and so to define a little bit better
what it is that
i mean with that there is the idea of
multi-scale you're looking at a problem
on multiple scales of abstraction
multiple levels of abstraction
at multiple sizes and multiple
granularities
and really looking at what it is that
you can do
to optimize the entire system to
save energy to run as fast as possible
to save space
to make it mobile or to move things
from batch processing into real
real-time activities
and so that's really where you can look
at the transistor level the bit level
the arithmetic level micro architecture
level parallel node level
complete system level and once you look
at all of these things
and you go top down then you go bottom
up again and you play
a few times back and forth you you
figure out what it is that you can do on
each of these levels like on the
complete system level you would like to
balance compute storage and i o
on the parallel node level you would
like to maximize
utilization of your computation and your
interconnect or communication and people
will talk about the
computation to communication ratio of of
their parallel programs
on the micro architecture level you
probably want to minimize data movement
because moving the data around
is the thing that takes a lot of time
takes a lot of power
and is just very inconvenient
there is the arithmetic level where
actually we want to compute something
so what is that thing that we want to
compute well there's going to be numbers
going in numbers going out but it's not
really numbers right it's discretized
representations of these numbers using
bits and so you have to think of range
precision accuracy
uh discrete discretization in space
and time and value all together
and so today scientists all worry about
time and space
and they don't like to worry about value
and the way they do that is they just
say well it's going to be double
precision floating point
and whatever that means that's just
going to be good enough
and if that doesn't work we'll call in
one of the experts who knows how to fix
that and if it costs a hundred times
more
to pay for the electricity to run that
computation that's not my problem i
i really don't don't care about that
because somebody else is going to fix
that
so here by looking at this
discretization as time space
and value you get to play around with
these things in an interesting way
on the bit level the way you encode your
problem
can have massive impact as you know if
you think about an actual physical
problem
you look at the physics and then you say
well i'm going to encode the physics in
a certain way
i'm going to encode the earth as as
being these parameters
and they're going to be able to take
these sets of values that's an encoding
and if you pick an optimal encoding for
that clearly
that can uh improve the efficiency of
the computation and finally
as you go down to the transistor level
you're actually playing with voltages
and
and uh assuming that these mean zero and
one but you can actually
look at that as activities that take
power
take electricity and can look at that so
here is a conceptual view of what it is
that we're talking about
there are cpus in the system there is
data flow engines in the system which we
are prototyping on fpgas
and there is an infiniband network that
we use to connect these two worlds
together
flexibly because you never know how many
of the cpus and how many
of the data flow engines you may need at
runtime and so in a flexible environment
you may have an application that takes a
few of these
and a lot more of these down here
another application may take lots of
these up here
and just a few of these down here and so
we have a multi-user
multi-application environment that
manages all of this for us
and we have the different levels of
abstraction as well with the
processors the complete system that you
have here
down to the chip the arithmetic units in
here the memory the bits and the
transistors to drive these
so that's kind of the global picture and
uh
i thought of starting this talk with uh
with the result
and then working backwards on how we
arriving to that so once you put all of
these things together and
you take commercial applications and you
put them out there and you optimize them
and you run them
and you compare against different types
of technologies
here this is a comparison against the
latest cpus that that you can buy in
high performance computing so
high-end servers as you take the latest
uh
data flow computing solution that we
have and you compare to the latest
processors that you can buy on the high
end and you see a ratio of
between 20 and 60 times
in terms of the size of the machine so
you have a certain size of the machine
you say one of these nodes does the same
amount of computation as
20 to 60 of these others and the
examples here this is a pde solver for
acoustic uh
modeling in geophysics and that's
solving the acoustic wave equation
with a finite difference model this is
the local area model
which is coming from weather prediction
so there
the pressure is being modeled on
two-dimensional finite
difference planes that are then being
stacked on top
of each other this is trace processing
also from
the seismic industry there is imaging
there is a fluid flow which is uh
basically
uh two fluids mixing inside of a
material and
seeing how one fluid pushes the other uh
and then
this is uh mainly the activity that
we talked about in in one of these
previous talks here
uh the finance activity that we've done
with uh
jp morgan and uh steven here knows
a lot more about that so i'll just skip
over to
to the next bit so what does this really
mean
so if you look at let's say a 33x
multiple as we had on the previous slide
you have four days going to maybe three
hours
you have scenarios that you're computing
you may be able to compute 10 risk
scenarios going up to 330.
if you look at the power consumption one
megawatt going down to
36 kilowatts if you think about it in
terms of spending
you say for every million dollar that
you spend on a computer system
with a standard microprocessor system
over three years you may be generating
one more million in terms of electricity
costs
and just operational costs around that
air conditioning and just maintaining
the environment
and with that this basically drops down
by by more than 10x
for every dollar that you spend on
buying it so so it there is a
uh different the different dimensions
that you can look across and say given
that i have a budget given i have a
power budget a space budget
or just the weight budget in terms of
carrying it around
uh there is different consequences so
then the question is these numbers just
look very much out of whack with
anything that one sees
typically people talk about 10 or 20
percent clearly there is
the downside of this and downside of
this is that there is effort involved
you actually have to spend effort to
move things over into this world
and optimize them one application at a
time you can't just take your
open source applications and move them
onto this technology
it takes effort to take some time and
that's what this talk is really about to
show you how we do this
so what we have here is uh the main
components
we have the architecture which is
basically a static data flow
architecture and there's a lot of
literature on these types of
architectures out there
we will have the management of the
transactions moving the data around
in that kind of environment optimization
of the data movement
across the machine there is the
application programming interface how do
you actually do it what's the
programming interface how do you get
programs written in c plus class fortran
or any other language over into this
world of computing in space
and then the application areas uh where
i'll talk a little bit more about
particular applications and then stephen
is going to
to follow up with a little bit more
in-depth analysis
of the risk domain where we're looking
at computing
scenarios across wide ranges of
parameter changes
so i'm going to go out on the limb here
and uh simplify the problem a little bit
of course the
the actual computation is a lot more
complicated
but a very very simple pipeline if you
just think of it as a string
of units with the stages here
if you want to compute these five
operations
on a large stream of data right
and you say i have a certain
data rate that i want to reach i would
like to compute
one gigabyte per second of results
right how would i do that well you need
to stream the data in here
at one gigabyte per second and you
stream it out here
at one gigabyte per second right
and so the clock frequency for this
the minimal clock frequency that you can
use
is the data rate right you need a clock
tick you need a tick of the clock to get
the result out otherwise
it's not uh it's not going to be easy to
manage
you could get more but but then you're
having signals floating on the wires
and that's all very very inconvenient
and so one clock tick per result
if you look at the power consumption uh
equation you see well
it depends on capacitance voltage and
the frequency
so in order to minimize power if we
assume
that the capacitance in the voltage is
the same
then all we need to do is minimize the
clock frequency
if we want the minimal power for a
particular computation
the minimal power arises if you have the
minimal clock frequency what is the
minimal clock frequency it's the data
rate because you cannot have a lower
clock frequency
than the data rate and so then all you
have to convince
yourself is that the largest chip that
you can buy
from uh most major companies today are
driven by whatever can be manufactured
and put into a package
so the largest chip from company a will
probably be
as large as the largest chip from
company b
and that will set the capacitance and uh
then one can argue around about the
voltage here a little bit
uh but i won't be doing that too much
my argument is really more about the
clock frequency being minimal
and for a set of capacitance voltage
that gives you the minimum power
consumption here
and so here is what you get you get the
assembly line
and the computations come out and they
plop out one at a time
and interestingly in the manufacturing
world this is also the most efficient
way that people figured out
how to manufacture things if you want to
manufacture a lot
if you just want to make two or three of
something then this is of course
overhead because you have to build a
whole factory and you have to make this
assembly line and
hire people you could just have made one
in the meantime but if you want to make
thousands of them then it makes sense to
sit down
build the factory make the assembly
lines make the whole thing move here
build a nice track
get the thing to move and plop them out
one at a time
and so now there are a few uh
i'll call them theorems but uh
really i guess uh these are more just uh
statements on uh what i see as
conclusions from all of this
which is that the time to compute one
million results is equal to the number
of
results per clock cycle times the clock
frequency
right so you have the clock frequency as
it flops through this is the number of
results you're going to get
so you can compute how long it will take
to process
let's say 1 million numbers what this
also means is that
it doesn't depend on the number of
operations that you have in here
so time the computation time the time it
takes to compute
now only depends on the amount of data
it doesn't depend anymore
on the number of operations as long as
the number of operations
is a lot smaller than the amount of data
so if you look at computation you have
less arithmetic more data
then you can just project how long it
will take to compute this
now the second piece is that for any
desired data rate of results
the minimum clock frequency is equal to
the data rate
right because you cannot have a lower
clock frequency
and then finally assuming
the the capacitance and voltage is not
causing further trouble
the minimal clock frequency brings the
minimal power consumption
yes i get the feeling that you're
leading us down the path that power is
the
is the thing we want to be worried about
but
if if just using what you've given me
you lower the frequency
and maybe um you save some power but
um things if your results per cycle is
the same it takes longer you spend the
same energy
and i would claim it's the energy you
want to look at okay
um that that may be true
so changing the frequency does nothing
right so you also need to be faster
so as long as you're as long as you're
not slower
if you are a lot faster and you use less
energy
then you've saved saved the the power
so i can i can talk to you about this
after the talk but i think that there is
there is a way to combine that with the
execution time this is just the power
argument
right clearly if you take longer to
compute and you reduce the clock
frequency
then you haven't gained anything right
exactly yeah missing the frequency
the energy doesn't go up by it's not
linear related to frequency
as as frequency goes up the power
consumption goes up by a power of
two or three
so it's it's a uh power and time
argument of course
and then you need to look at how much
time you're spending um
in terms of the overall structure
drilling down a little bit into the
details
there is a certain amount of control
flow that you have in an application and
you can put some of that
over on the microprocessor you can put
some of it into
the data flow architecture and have
certain amount of
local control flow here and you can have
also a
certain amount of control for in
switching out different configurations
here into the chip so really you have
three types of control flow
um and the rest is the data flow through
this chip
and the memory that you have here now
i've drawn this very small but
this can actually be 24 48 uh
382 it's 884 gigabytes i believe so
so you could have a substantial amount
of memory here attached
to this ring where you're rotating these
things through
and so all you have to do in order to
compute is to
pass uh bits from one side to the other
and i'm grateful to
to bob for uh for this particular slide
it's uh
it's one of my favorites but
instead of looking at that for too long
uh once you look at this
what can you do with that well it really
spans the idea of data
networking and computing so if you think
of the data flow technology here in the
middle
as providing connectivity uh storing
data
and providing computation all in one go
you can build machines that deal with
the computational part
the connectivity or the data bit and so
there are some examples
around here of uh what we've done or or
what could be done
uh from pdes and algorithms on the
computation side
to connectivity where in finance
we are doing a low latency trading
working with exchanges and and just
basically moving data
packets around in the network over to
data where there's a lot of potential on
the database side
dealing with expanding and compressing
data
caching it searching all these types of
activities
are really interesting as you put that
together this is how they actually look
like and
there are a few here also both in the
geophysics department and
in the gates building there is a c
series which combines the cpus and the
data flow engines
there's a data flow appliance which sits
on infiniband
and there is a networking appliance
which kind of sits
on a network and works on the data
passing through with a tcp stack with
decoding of the data
and then just looking into the packet
layer 3
4 six seven anyone that you want
so getting back from the from the uh
real world out there um i think some of
you may have seen this question it's
it's one of the big questions
out there
does anybody know the answer to that one
this is presumably based base 13 no no
no
it's it's just just regular decimal
108. 408 looked up on the calculator
very very good so
i gave this talk uh or at least this
slide uh a while ago
and i give handouts and on the handout
i had a different number i changed
this to 16 was very mean
and i asked the same question and
of course the answer came very quickly
as
408 because somebody just looked it up
on the handles oh it's written in the
handout i'll just read it out from the
handout
right and so given that the number was
wrong obviously that didn't work out
uh the nice thing about this is that it
tells us something about
um about thinking so i've stolen this
question uh from
from this book by uh daniel kahneman
nobel prize in economics
uh which is a brilliant piece of work um
talking about 17 times 24 and saying
that
you look at uh let's say back to
and there is no way that you can prevent
yourself from reading it
there is no way that you can say no i'm
not going to as long as you look at it
your brain will read it and it will tell
you what it is if you want or not
it's irrelevant this on the other hand
takes effort you would have to actually
spend effort to calculate how much it is
it's possible
you know how to do it and you can do it
but you're not going to because it's
too much effort and that's because it
requires you to use system two
and this is the naming that that
kahneman has for these two bits of your
brain
system one is very fast hard to control
and it will tell you that this number is
about 400.
it's it's somewhere there and you know
it's about 400 you're not going to say
because it doesn't make any sense to say
that
but you know it's about 400 you don't
know that it's 408
and you're most likely not going to put
in the effort to do it because it's not
useful
system 2 is slow easy to control
it's also very lazy it's going to try to
prevent to spend the effort to actually
do this
as much as it possibly can and the
reason is
is because it's an energy optimization
right you want to be able to do
as much computation as possible as
minimum
energy as possible and uh so
you know let's just kind of take that as
a piece of information that that's a
nice way to think of things
um and then i just dug back to one of my
favorite statements
and i like particularly how how this was
written
says that we are forced to recognize
really suggest he's not very happy about
it he doesn't like it doesn't want to
have it
but something has forced him to
recognize this
that there's this possibility of
constructing a hierarchy of memories
which is going to create
pain and suffering for for the remainder
of mankind
and each of these is going to have
greater capacity than the preceding one
but it's going to be less quickly
accessible
and so regardless of any progress that
we've made
any memory technology that we've seen so
far if it's bigger it's lower
if it's smaller it's faster it's just
how it is right so any the bigger you
make the memory this lan
and here it is it's already laid out
very nicely so we have our two problems
laid out for us
we have
if somebody invented a small slow memory
nobody would care
yes so we're throwing away
you know if we do the standard you know
uh four coordinate graphs there's
there's areas where even if you had
something nobody cares
well it is true that i'm assuming that
every player in the game
is going to use his dominant strategy in
order to accomplish his task
right so so you want to you want to do
the best you can on all fronts
if you of course you can ruin it but if
you do the best you can on the small
memory and you do the best you can
on the big memory then it turns out that
that you have that and so now combining
these two things
and just saying but let's compute a
function let's compute a
an elementary function very simple one
input one output
is not not too complicated and you say
well
we could look it up in a table it's just
a function right
or uh we could use arithmetic we could
do polynomials and
and we could do rational approximations
and
all kind of other wild things it turns
out that the optimal way to compute it
in terms of
the time it takes to compute it the
resources it takes is somewhere in the
middle it's a trade-off between
remembering some of the things
and computing some other things and so
that's a very nice trade-off that you
can play as an optimization
on the micro architecture level just
just an example
um we've we've done a paper a little
while ago
uh with a brute force method so just
enumerate it all of the different ways
or many different ways
of precision and range so you want a
certain precision for your
sine or cosine and you have a certain
range that you're looking at
given the range and the precision
there's a different method that is
optimal
and there's quite significant
differences in the method so you can see
for sine
with 12 bits of range and four bits of
precision
it turns out that the polynomial of
order two
is the ideal thing with a table that
gives you the
the two coefficients at time and and the
precision that you want
for the two is is nine and then 31 bits
so so there is different optimal ones
this is a
polynomial this is a table with a
polynomial
and up here as you get more precision
and more range
you're going to start to see tp3 which
is which is three
three coefficients and bigger tables but
there's a different
optimum point for how much memory and
how much compute you want to do
and so that's just an example for large
programs you want to do such an
optimization by thinking about the
algorithm and figuring out how much you
want to remember how you want to encode
your problem
what is your data structure and what is
your arithmetic
what are your computations and that
trade-off
of how much you store in memory and how
much you actually compute
is one of the key trade-offs in
optimizing the balance
between how much you need to communicate
afterwards and how much you need to
compute
but in order to optimize the computer
system that way you need to understand
the partial differential equation you
need to understand define a difference
method
you need to understand what the
scientist has in mind when he wrote this
and what he actually wants to compute
and so that's slightly inconvenient for
for somebody who lives in the horizontal
world who just wants to optimize
a microprocessor without understanding
uh how
you know imaging works or how partial
differential equations get created from
a physical problem
so that's the kind of different
perspective that you get by by looking
at it that way
back to system one and system two uh the
way we are dealing with this
is by putting high throughput memory in
the low latency memory
microprocessors and a data flow
on the other side and uh
that way
i guess we've lost the sound on this one
but you can imagine that
this was uh there we go
very nice
so so you have the assembly line idea of
of getting things done
more more efficiently and then you have
the artisan here who goes and does the
whole thing
one program he goes through the program
step by step and does everything that it
tells them to then there's some
collaboration needed because
obviously these guys individually don't
know what they're building
uh and and this guy here uh is is not
necessarily
worried about how long it's going to
take him to to make his uh
his artistic uh component there
and so the collaboration of these two is
uh
is the way we are we are putting these
together so
now moving on to the programming
interface
if you let's say have a convolution
which is a very simple standard
computation
and you say you have this program and it
goes through the loop and
coefficients and you have a
two-dimensional
array and you want to compute this
stencil here that looks like this with
coefficients one two three
zero one two three four and uh
you want to express that as a data flow
architecture the way we are writing this
is simply the same way as it would look
in a regular program
except that your index into data
turns into delay
fifos on the hardware side so you're now
having instead of a register file you're
simply storing the numbers
locally inside of these little memories
and if you write it this way which is
very similar to
this here accepted the index now becomes
memory
and that local memory allows you to
stream the
data from one side through the stencil
back out
without having any events without having
any memory access
other than of course the input stream
and the output stream
and also allows you to cascade these
down how much memory do you need locally
well locally you need
as much memory as the distance between
the coefficients
and so now the job goes back to the
scientists to say
what is the stencil that you can build
that minimizes the distance between the
coefficients
and most people may not have thought
about the problem that way
that they can optimize computation by
looking at the distance between their
coefficients
in their operator yes some of the way
you program a gpu
maybe okay yes so um
there may be similarities to all kind of
things it is thinking about
where the data is and where it's going
and so you have the same thing on the
gpu you have to think uh
think about when the data is moving from
one side of the pci express bus to the
other
and which memory it sits in so that's
kind of the
the level of similarity and and that
kind of gets expressed in
in your description i i would disagree
with that statement because
what you're doing is you're allocating
specific hardware resources
and the gpu is i mean
as we sit here now they have caches and
so forth the main difference being they
just don't have coherency in the cache
there are there are some things that are
slightly similar
and there are some things that are very
difficult there's no specific allocate
you're allocating a resource for the
coefficient that's going to stay there
the entire time that your data is
streaming through the stencil
yes is going to rely on a texture
cache that's that part is that part is
different yes
no i'm going to go saying program this
algorithm
i'm going to explicitly allocate or
assign part of shared memory
to um to store uh
values i'm gonna use over and over again
i don't yeah the other similarities
programming in terms of kernels
well that's i
fine i i find the hardware description
to be
very different from writing
this is this is really computing in
space you're describing the structure
while programming the gpus is describing
threads of computing in time
so that's a difference the similarity is
that you have a heterogeneous system
where there is the main system and then
there is something else on the pci
express bus
and you have to worry about computation
here and over there so there are some
things that are similar
and some things that are different i
think we should be able to to agree on
that
kind of general statement here the main
point that i do want to make
is as you stream this data through
uh you just have a function call here
and then you stream it through the
stencil and you get it back out
you can now look at the real stencil so
now at the real stencil again uh
uh thanks to uh uh to our
collaborators in the geophysics
department here
um we have some uh some actual real
stencil here and so you have a lot more
coefficients now the difference
here is that the distance between this
point and this point in the 3d array
can be quite large and you have to store
the entire thing
in the local memory and so one way to
optimize this if you look at the cpu
code
you have the inner loop which is bound
by the amount of local memory the outer
loop
where you have the the time update
where where it's uh i guess main memory
bound because you have to hold the
entire array in main memory
and so on the cpu the time is determined
by the number of coefficients
so the less coefficients you have the
better because every multiply takes time
to actually do the computation for us on
the other hand
that's not true and there is this uh
paper that we wrote
that uses more coefficients
but the distance between the top and the
bottom coefficient is smaller
and it turns out that this here can be
well at the at the top about three times
faster so that's three times faster by
using a different stencil
of course i couldn't develop this
stencil right i have no idea how this
stencil is being developed
i need to talk to a domain expert to
figure out how to change the physics
around
so that i can have a stencil that looks
like this
and then of course the impact of these
on the time steps and
on the discretization in space uh is is
all
left to to be figured out but at the
same time i can say if you could do that
hey it it runs a lot faster and turns
out it's possible
so so that's one example of an
optimization
that is enabled by this new technology
it turns out this actually runs in the
same
or same time or slower on the cpu
and it's not an optimization that you
would typically do or want or
or look for in any system that computes
in time
but when you compute in space turns out
it's very useful to have and so that was
that was a very insightful result
a while ago and so looking back at the
applications where do you search things
well the application with the finite
difference and it is used in imaging
so you have these boats and they go
across the ocean and then you can look
down and image underground 3d images
of the earth to see the various layers
by
solving the acoustic wave equation there
is a wave going down from the boats
hitting the rock cascading back up and
you have the largest moving object here
that we can see from space which are
these cables 10 kilometers long
all full of sensors that help to do that
imaging
and so in this environment you have a
tremendous amount of data
hitting these boats at every second
basically more than one gigabyte every
10 seconds
so that's that's the one to compute on
and then you look at
what did people accomplish with this in
terms of actual
performance so here is an example
published uh
by an oil company of uh using these data
flow computers
and saying well this is using eight
cards each card
uh you know maybe 50 watts 70 watts
something like this and uh measuring
the actual performance this is the
problem size so here is
a small problem a bigger problem an even
bigger problem and a gigantic problem
and on the gigantic problem here you see
that the actual equivalence of these
eight cards
goes to a thousand nine hundred cpu
course
you say well how is that possible well
it's such a large problem
that didn't fit in the local caches
anywhere it didn't fit in the memory
systems
and by building a computer
that has enough memory that has enough
space to hold all of this locally close
to the compute
and computing on it at the same rate
close by
you can actually achieve at the corner
cases very extreme things
and so then finally you get something
that looks like this where the wave is
propagating and you have that
simulation and you can look at that in
real time on your screen
rather than as a batch job overnight or
you come back in the morning and you say
oh how did my simulation work out
oh now i have to change my my model salt
may not be going this way it may
actually be much bigger
so that's kind of the environment here
there is another example
we now have a university program
where scientists are studying how to put
algorithms onto this
architecture in a variety of domains
this one is astrochemistry
looking at images from the hubble
telescope here
and then looking at different uh
chemical compounds in space
and figuring out which ones might be out
there what the stars or
or whatever else is out there may be
made of and again as the problem size
increases
the data flow computing uh solution
picks up and it's not that it's faster
than the competing technologies
it's really that it's less slower than
the competing technologies
as the problem size increases and that
can be a significant advantage
as long as you have a big enough problem
so for small problems
down here doesn't make any sense as you
increase the problem size
uh you see the uplift of this way of
doing it
here's another one numerical example
done for the pitevsky equation
there is there is another one here for a
microscopy
where you have very very large images
coming from from the microscope up
into the compute engine and you want to
differentiate and distinguish very fine
bits in here
simulations of the brain are very very
popular these days
so also very compute intensive it looks
like everybody wants to build a computer
that works like the brain
and so this is at the university of
chicago they've implemented this model
which studies the different connections
and links between the different cells
and they managed to simply simulate much
larger systems
than they could simulate before so it's
not so much about saving time all the
time sometimes it's just about being
able to
compute a much larger problem and uh
putting that into your engine
here's another one
which is a bit more of a of a mystery to
me
just from a from a scientific
perspective but
that's a project running at uh ucl
looking at uh
the different chemical structures
and there's a variety of other things
there is earthquake prediction uh there
is nanophotonics
there is graphics virtual environments
with a real time requirement to move
data in and out of glasses of
of screens of things on the walls on
tables
there is of course the bioinformatics
field which requires a lot of data so so
looking at all of this
one question may be okay so so what kind
of algorithms really
fit well to to this type of technology
and as i've said of course the problem
size is a very big component so having a
big enough problem
is very key but then algorithm buys
convolution finite difference
is kind of the trivial one to explain
and the easiest one to catch
at the same time conjugate gradient
optimizations
things where you have large amounts of
data that need to be computed on
over and over again where you have a
static
understanding of how the data is going
to move through your system you just
have to look at the entire
set of data all the time to search
through it
finite elements spice matrix solvers a
little bit more tricky
now here that is one of the key
applications that is really hard to
parallelize and so people achieve
parallelizations of maybe 10
12 20 and are really excited about it
most finite element solvers
run on workstations because a large
parallel system wouldn't actually make a
difference
and so over here you can think of the
challenge
as building the optimal memory
controller for each one
of these sparse matrices and
representing the data in its optimal way
and and again here this is a publication
that that came out here at stanford at
hot chips a while ago
where schlumberger showed how they could
actually
improve on on their performance of these
types of algorithms
there is some database work again
something completely different
far out on the data side encoding how to
match up large amounts of data
some great work being done here at
stanford the
the computer systems lab and and then
finally
uh or or maybe actually primarily very
interesting for
finance and risk runs
and so i'll just pass on the the stage
here to
stephen to tell us a lot more about what
it means to compute a lot more when
you're faced with
risk and operational situations out
there in the field
so that
may not be as easy as i thought
yep
to the slides layer to compare a local
table and
logic operation
yes yeah here i think
i think you're comparing tables and
operations right but i think table is
not the only way to do one operation
one is that i think we can build some
kind of specific circuits
right like for example in an extreme
case
if we only take one operation like
n logic operation so we have
two inputs and one outputs if we are
using a table we need four memories
right but in in in operation
uh circuits we only need two or four
transistors yes
so so so so this is equivalent
and like memory is equivalent to
circuits so
for more complicated programs we can
also do some kind of things
so has anyone done this kind of work now
that transfer a function into a circuit
instead of table
um when you say circuit do you mean
a logic circuit uh i mean
anything so in fact you can transfer any
table
into a logic circuit by just looking at
the table as a truth table
and doing logic minimization on the
table that's typically equivalent
you can think of the table as one table
or you can think of it as lots of little
tables
and then the question is how many tables
do you need right so i'm simplifying
here
right so there is there is a way to
think of it as multiple tables
then there is a way to combine tables in
a different way
right and then there is a way to do
arithmetic in a different way
right so there's a wide range of options
that you have here and i've just shown a
little one
um in in real applications we have
looked at
geophysical applications where you
cannot store the entire data
in dram and so you have to store it back
out to disk
and so instead of storing the entire
data back out to disk
we could also recompute it over and over
again
as we do our iterations because
computation for us takes space
and not always time we can do some
recomputation in available space
without slowing down the computation and
so trading off
uh in solving pds trading off the
storage of data
as it is going out with recomputing it
every time step which maybe
may look as inefficient but ends up
moving
less data around that's so
you can think of having a computation
and you compute forwards and backwards
in the computation
and you can do that over and over again
to save having to remember
what that number was so instead of
remembering you can always recompute
and that's what this is trying to
explain to to trade off as well
except that this is easier to show you
can trade off
remembering what the number is with the
way
to get there right you can remember a
telephone number
or you can remember the person who knows
that telephone number you just ask them
right and so that's the i'm sorry i'm
not very familiar with your
specific techniques but okay i have
uh got my answer for my well well sorry
last question you can minimize the table
yes yeah of course
and and another question is that uh
i think this is kind of you know what
user trade off
your you're you're trying to use more
memory to
to get uh that to you to to save time or
your time to save memory so so
have you got any kind of you know
equipment
like one second equals to 10 giga memory
something
like that or in more general circuitry
i think that kind of equivalence between
time
and and space in computing and space in
memory
is very application dependent and so it
depends
really on what you're doing and you
would have to derive that yourself
as you look at the particular
application what we do do is
we would look at excel spreadsheets
uh create a little model of of that
computations and this much data in this
much data out that
typically by putting together 20 30 40
numbers on a spreadsheet
you can model the underlying activity
and you can trade off the the two sides
very nicely so it's all about modeling
the computation
as a flow of data across a system and if
you know your bandwidths across the
buses
and you know the capacity of of your
chips
then that is not very difficult
then last question i think
one program can have internal states
right for example i input one
a one inside the program it may give out
zero or may give up one depending on
which state it is in
so but as table is not i
i think a table don't have internal
space right well
the tables and this table is a read-only
table
for computing but it turns out inside of
of our chips you have um srams
and so you can read and write them at
the same time you could think of this
table as something that can be
written and read at the same time
and so if you just have lots of these
and you can read and write all of them
at the same time you can think
it could also store it you can tell it
that it should be just storing it and
remembering
it doesn't matter so that's just a
feature of of sram
you can make it remember or you can make
it
change itself for example i'm treating a
program like a black box i don't know
okay i'm i am not giving any dynamic
instructions to it
i give in one in one day time they
it pops out on another yes and this uh
i give the same data it may pop up
different uh
data because of its internal state yes
then cannot table do this to
this table can store state yes
any more questions i think if you store
the table state you still need some kind
of operation
units inside i mean processors inside
too
i mean the table is not not purely a
memory it's
it's a pure memory okay it's a pure
memory and
there is also you can create any logic
circuit
out of memory because a logic circuit is
a truth table
is a memory and so they're equivalent
and you can create any
functionality out of both memories and
logic
it's the same okay
i've questioned about um the physical
map back to power
so cv squared f okay makes sense if
we've got a chip or something
but if we're looking at something like
for example gates that propagate
you know that are a clock tree or
something like that then the the problem
space becomes a little more complex
because we have optical alternatives
have you explored those and is that part
of your strategy
um we are not making any chips ourselves
and so we are we are reliant on the
research of chip makers to to make use
of these technologies
and uh i am certain there there is some
great things coming up on on that front
and so we'll certainly make use of this
to trade off again
uh one one kind of uh
one kind of resource with another kind
of resource
on the lowest level
so yes i think that that could be very
useful
okay
and just look at some of the more
practical sides of what we've been doing
with the technology and how we
we've taken the the more computational
side
in geophysics and pushed it into the
finance
side of the world in a more generic way
and just start really with a notion of
risk
it was quite interesting when i actually
looked it up someone asked me what risk
actually you know what was the origin of
the word
uh and it's quite confusing there's the
greeks claim it
the uh the romans claim it the italians
claim it the spanish claim it the french
claim
uh but today we basically talk about
risk as being any deviation
from an optimum solution or process uh
usually described in terms of expected
loss
the expected loss didn't just pop out of
the woodwork either
and this is a kind of just a bit of a
tongue-in-cheek
skip through history uh trying to give
you some feel for how
risk came about um kind of pre-1494
um pacquiaoli's coin tossing puzzle
solution uh there seems to have been a
general view that risk was kind of
fate kind of you know um it happened it
was kind of the will of the gods it just
was there
and then in 1494 pacquiao was sitting
there tossing the coins and figured out
there was might be a solution to it
uh and then there was a whole bunch of
probability theory solutions
and bernoulli's laws law of large
numbers
and interesting interestingly even some
of the bernoulli arithmetic is still
used now for
in a slightly bizarre way by some of the
exchanges
1738 demoira develops a normal
distribution
and i stand to be corrected on any of
these dates i tried to check them for at
least two sources but i could be wrong
uh 1763 bayes develops his idea of prior
beliefs
and in 1800s finally the theory of
expected loss
was developed
and kind of bringing that up to date uh
we got from measurement to precision in
only 50 years
which is quite interesting 50 1952
markovitz developed
the idea of diversification don't put
all your eggs in one basket
especially if it's mortgages and then in
uh sharp and lintner developed the
capital asset pricing model
a way of looking at the the market and
comparing things with the average market
return in a
in a very uh simple way and in 76 ross
developed the no arbitrage theory
and we were kind of off to the races
that it was then the idea you could
replicate
any um risky uh
security by a combination of a risky and
riskless security
and it was always possible to price
things on a no arbitrage basis
1992 farmer and french push that into
the multi-factor area
and they started thinking about risk
across multiple factors and then in 1994
the
uh and i don't i don't claim this is
kind of a jp morgan thing but it
it is a recorded fact 1994 uh dennis
weatherston the then chairman of jp
morgan was sitting at a board meeting
one day and said
i'd really like to know how much on a
daily basis
uh we could lose on a just on an average
kind of a day
let's say with 95 certainty and he said
oh well you know five days forward 10
days forward 15 days forward
just tell me how much we're likely to
lose with a 95 97
99 expectation and so
uh value at risk was what it was known
was born
and very quickly because of a bunch of
things but
not least of which jp morgan had a lot
of representation on the
bank for international settlement basel
committee uh the
var idea value at risk became adopted as
standard in 1998
and so everyone's kind of been focusing
on that since
but what's actually more interesting in
some respects is to think about loss
versus risk
um and we can think about really
categorizing risks and losses based on
the degree of severity and the frequency
of occurrence
and there's definitely a bit of
confusion going on about probability and
frequency of occurrence
there's this kind of insistence and uh
innate belief that i can assign a
probability i can say i'm 62.7 percent
certain that the shares in apple will go
up by one cent or more tomorrow
and one of the things i quite like i've
been driving we've been driving around
in in
in the palo alto era over the last few
days and i particularly like
your fines uh there's the one thousand
dollar fine which i can kind of
understand that seems like a reasonable
rational number
then there's the 281 dollar fine and the
336 dollar fine
now i'm not quite sure that precision is
kind of you know intended or accidental
or
but there seems to be this kind of idea
that obviously that fine in some way
relates to some probability or frequency
of occurrence they must have come up
with that number from somewhere
hopefully they didn't just go 281 seems
like a good number today to wednesday
um so trying to categorize risks
and losses and think about the one
against the other and so looking at the
log of the frequency versus the log of
the severity
categorizing those risks into kind of
immaterial losses where
expected losses and risks are negligible
um things happen on a daily basis you
kind of lose stuff and it kind of part
of doing business
and then the top top corner nominal
operational risks where
expected losses are more important than
the risks um
so the actual loss or the shrinkage is
actually more important than the risk
that you're taking
taking ordinary operational risks where
we both expected risk and the expected
losses are significant
and then down here on the right hand
corner which are the much more
interesting ones
where the risks are much more important
than the expected losses
and there we're thinking particularly
in a wider context when you get
situations like ubs
suffered where a trader took many
billions of dollars worth of bets
and it wasn't the size of the loss that
was important it was the
impact on that institution's reputation
and the the then the consequent loss of
confidence in the institution
and the fact that many many many
billions of dollars drained out of the
institution
because there was a belief that actually
the risk that institution
didn't know what its risk was didn't
know whether or not people were
trustworthy
didn't know whether or not they could
measure the risk correctly and therefore
couldn't control it
and if you can't measure it you can't
control it so
really trying to think linked losses
together and kind of pushing the problem
slightly into a different dimension
uncertainty and risk and i am eternally
grateful to the uh
the well now now well quoted donald
rumsfeld as the unknown unknowns
uncertainty i think is probably the best
definition um going
uh but i particularly like the the side
comment that he also made
which is much less reported is that what
really hurts you is the no
knowns these are the things that you
know you know but you don't want to
admit you know
um and they're the things that are going
to cost you the most money and so
really uncertainty uh no probabilities
we've got no idea we've got no privacy
distribution probability of the third
world war well well
i don't know could be one might not be
one might be happening now we don't know
but what we're trying to do is to model
in some sense
produce a model of dynamic behavior to
contain those uncertainties if you like
and come to something that's actually
measurable so
now we can hopefully come up with known
unknowns we actually put some boundaries
around this we can measure probabilities
however subjective and however
sort of ephemeral they are we can
actually come up with a probability
and a good example of that is in the
correct derivatives market where
there are default curves for pretty much
all the major names
and they get quoted and they get written
every night and people look at them and
they value securities
and they're all absolutely certain that
there is a 96.71
probability that the government of italy
will default by
in 30 years time not quite sure where
that comes from but allegedly that's
there and
everyone marks it every night and
interestingly they all expect a priority
across the industry
that if that were to happen there would
be a 40 recovery um in other words you'd
lose 60 but you definitely get 40
back and all the banks use it so
probability
interesting but our frequency likelihood
and chance the same as probability
because we do seem to mix them up
when we try to measure risk
so what we're really interested with air
with the data flow technology if you
like trying to bind the thing back
is that down here many institutions look
at point estimates and var is a really
good example of a point estimate
uh you know we are 95 certain that we
won't lose 120 million dollars
in the next seven working days uh point
estimate and interestingly if you come
up with a var estimate
once the loss goes beyond that the var
the var
um the simple var methodology has
nothing to tell you about how big that
loss might be
what it might look like in the tail even
if you try a different probability
distribution it doesn't really tell you
anything it says
okay now you've lost a lot more money
that's interesting
and if you read this a very interesting
comment you can google it and find out
on on bloomberg one of the bloomberg
reporters did a kind of a really a very
surgical dissection of the recent loss
by jp morgan and i can kind of talk
about it now i'm not there
and look back with a sort of certain
amount of detachment
and he went he went through day by day
by day and how they actually managed to
lose
eight billion dollars from when
initially they thought they were only
going to lose one billion dollars
and very interestingly right in the
middle of the process they changed their
var methodology and the var methodology
between day one
and day two half the amount of r and so
suddenly they're off to the races they
could double their risk
and so really what they were doing was
if you like they were assuming
that the numbers down here were good
yeah actually they were saying they were
very confident about them
and they were assuming really that the
models were deterministic they were
avoiding the complexity and avoiding the
uncertainty
and what we're trying to push the
technology here towards giving people is
the ability to look at non-deterministic
models
via scenario planning so expanding the
universe and thinking about the
the measurement problem much more deeply
so why do we use scenario analysis why
why is it important well
to give us a dynamic response to risk so
particular
in particular linking actions and
choices to outcomes of uncertain events
in other words we should be better
prepared by value evaluating sequential
and concurrent events
not just saying right okay let's bump
interest rates and see what that means
what really hurts you are the
combinations of events and a good
example of that
is um when multiple firms
go go bankrupt you know so if you have
one one
default let's say gm defaulted gm
defaulting didn't hurt that many people
what hurt was the clustering of defaults
consequent increases in cumulative
likelihood of events occurring
so people one one firm went down another
phone went down another phone went down
and typically not many excuse me risk
systems can evaluate that they typically
look at one scenario
draw the lines and say that's the number
we're exposed to they go to the
regulators and they say
actually we are 95 certain we won't lose
120 million dollars
in the next seven days so dynamic
response to risk
value of information scenarios are very
useful for getting a perspective on the
value of information and decision making
and reducing the error rate and avoiding
short-termism
typically a lot of risk in the financial
system is
focused on making a short-term gain it's
not an accident that
financial institutions re-value their
trading books every day
and in fact the more enlightened ones
are running and revaluing them and
calculating the risk in pretty much in
real time
now yeah does that actually improve
the process no but what it does do is
that feedback route
does begin to reduce uncertainty if the
measure is correct
if you're looking at the wrong measure
then you're still screwed but if you're
actually thinking more widely about the
measure
and you're computing more frequently
it's a sort of a robust optimal control
argument you've got a feedback system in
there
and you're beginning to reduce the
uncertainty and then finally
risk management if you've got better
response you've got better information
and you're using perspective
risk management should decide enable you
to decide proactively and
act on those events that should be
guarded against and so avoid double
counting or missing of risks
and that that's really the driver for
why we've been doing what we've been
doing
so how do we go about there now the
scenario process well clearly we have to
identify the factors what things are
going to cause a problem
um why how and and establish behavioral
equations
then we determine a number of scenarios
i mean how many scenarios do we need
you know is it is the answer one a
thousand ten thousand a hundred thousand
people think of these in things in terms
of the normal distribution so clearly we
do ten thousand
we should get convergence well actually
if you've got a thousand different
factors feeding in
ten thousand scenarios isn't going to be
enough is a million enough
well then you begin to look at the
asymptotic behavior do you get
actually stability or do you just get
kind of noise at the end of the curve
and so determining the number of
scenarios is actually quite a tricky
thing
because not only do you need convergence
but you also need to think of
computational
cost and time constraints so it's no
good running a big scenario with lots
and lots of paths and lots of
simulations if it takes you six weeks to
do it when you need the numbers right
now
so speed and the ability to contain
and process large quantities of data
very quickly are key in the in this kind
of area
then obviously we have to be able to
compute the cash flows and event payoffs
just doing that is actually quite an
interesting exercise
and looking at the changes in value
associated with with assigning the
probabilities
um can actually be an interesting uh
exercise
uh in a lot of cases the accuracy of the
information feeding the cash flows
is far from good uh typically take bonds
for example where a lot of the
banks lost money trading bonds during
the uh the meltdown
um a lot of them pulled the information
off bloomberg well actually the
the accuracy of the bloomberg data is
only as good as the people feeding it
and if the people feeding it are under
pressure and they're trying to trade
like crazy they're not guess what
they're not going to be updating the
bloomberg information that's feeding
everyone else
so you do have to be very careful about
then assigning those probabilities
and looking and very carefully whether
or not they're objective or subjective
probabilities
and when you're assigning probabilities
to a scenario are you
are you saying that's your central
scenario are you planning your your
institution around that
what are you what are your views on the
actual wings of the situation
so how will i let's apply that more
generally then and look at some cases
how will snar analysis help me in my
portfolio should i invest in the s p
if so how much and when uh and if i
invest how should i protect my
investment
well this shows the s p going back quite
a way and you can see there's a really
nice pattern there
and you can kind of in historical terms
clearly
you should invest at the bottom and sell
at the top and it should be a very
simple thing walk away and we're all
rich
why is that not the case well it turns
out that it's actually not that easy
to achieve that for a variety of reasons
how do you now measure these things
should you look at the price to earnings
price to book price to cash flow price
to sales
price to earnings to growth or the
dividend yield each one of those things
will give you a different view of how
your portfolio should look
and more importantly how you should
change your portfolio any instant in
time
and so it isn't as simple if it was that
simple i wouldn't be here i'd be sitting
in the bahamas with a large stack of
money so
it's not as simple as it looks so we
need coverage
um information again is interesting
global events um as oscars mentioned
earlier
uh kind of looking at tsunamis and
hurricanes i mean one of the interesting
things with the uh with the japanese
problem that they had was they they
looked at tsunamis and they looked at
hurricanes but they didn't apply it to
what would happen if you had a nuclear
power station right on the coast
that was on a fault that was going to
get hit by a tsunami and so
actually looking at consequential series
of events
the ability to model high in higher
dimensions and think more rationally
but this applies to both ends of the the
time spectrum
on the one hand you have a kind of a
macroeconomic overview
but on the other hand you have rules
based on algorithmic trading that is
working
almost in real time in across a lot of
the markets now
other problems um this one i quite like
as a
as a problem i'm most certainly not a
geophysicist and bob will tell you that
absolutely definitively
no problem there but some of the the
information i sat and watched two
stanford videos the other evening which
i found very very interesting
um the deporter horizon problem there
was no mechanism for control of the
riser
or the the blowout preventer at the
surface so there's five thousand feet of
pipe from this
floating vessel down to the floor and
then thirteen thousand
feet of pipe to the actual hydrocarbons
um so now
when things fail you've got 18 000 feet
of combustible fluids
in a pipe that wide coming at you at
probably quite a good rate of knots
so when it hits there when it hits your
your vessel um
it's going to explode and there's going
to be a lot of mess and a lot of leak
and again loss of power that causes loss
of power loss of dynamic position in the
vessel and you've got a disaster
disconnecting from the riser was too
slow and the and the preventer failed
and then part of that blowout preventer
failed to cut the risers and so
well failed to seal the pipe and now
you've got a leak now interestingly we
were talking to
a certain oil company this morning about
this kind of idea and the
looking at the consequential risks yeah
looking at this event and then linking
it to this event and linking it to this
event
and their comment was well yeah that
would be interesting to do but there's
an awful lot of work and an awful lot of
computation and we've never really been
able to do that before
so we're trying to broaden the thoughts
on how our technology might be used
here's another one closer to home
valuing a startup um
so venture capitalists and we've talked
to quite a few venture capitalists this
week and it's been quite entertaining as
an exercise
um they value startups based on exit
value using projected earnings on a
multiple in the future
and then they discount the exit value of
the target rate of return very simple
and straightforward
so let's look at an early stage firm
currently losing money which is typical
with early stage firms
but expected to say make profits to say
you know 10 million in five years time
nice round numbers
at which point the earnings malta will
probably be in line for the industry
let's say it's a tech company
around about 40x so vcs often use a very
high target discount rate say 35 percent
which value would value the firm roughly
at about 89.2
million today so we've got two two
possibilities
the company goes public at 400 million
everyone goes home and is happy
or the company fails and is worth
nothing you'd be surprised at the number
of situations that they don't look at in
between there
they say oh let's just flex the discount
factor from the
discount rate from 35 to 50 and down to
20.
there's a very interesting study that
was done jointly by the bank of england
in the sec recently
about the impact of short-termism on
discounting and they looked across a
whole range of markets
and basically estimated a short-term
discount a short term is an
impact in discounting and it was
actually surprisingly high
and the estimate was that across several
markets there was an
over over rejection of projects of about
25 percent
due to excessive short-termism in the
discounting and
basically what we're saying is that
projects are getting thrown out the
window because
we're looking at them incorrectly now is
that the fact that this short-termism is
a reflection of the risk
or is it simply a reflection of the fact
that they're not doing enough scenarios
to consider the breadth of the terminal
values
widening the debate from banking to
insurance we've had you've certainly had
a few hurricanes recently and if you
look at a banking taxonomy of risk here
we had we think in terms of causes
events and consequences
from the insurance point of view we
think of perils exposures
occurrences or claims and losses and the
interesting thing there is that
we must be those those data to get a
handle on them must be capable of
measurement and determination
as well as immune to a manipulation
otherwise we have a moral hazard problem
i've got that twice sorry so what are
the commonalities
um in these problems well high
dimensionality many causative factors
uh factor into dependence clearly
there's a lot of feedback here in fact
there's one between the other
factor ordering is critical we can't
simply run arbitrary combinations of
factors
and that's what many institutions do
they sit down they say
well here's today's today's environment
we'll simply bump it by 50
up and 50 down and we'll do this and we
do this and it's very arbitrary
and effectively what they're doing is
they're not spanning the event space
they're not doing it consistently
they're simply doing the combinatorics
and the critical thing here is to think
about the permutations here
because ordering and combinations is
actually critical when you're looking at
risk
the the whether or not you know blowout
preventer explodes at this particular
fails at this particular point
whether an explosion happens here
whether interest rates change here which
causes exchange rates to change there
the risk view is actually quite
different
and you can't simply run arbitrary
combinations of factors so
a permutative approach is required to
span the event space
and then obviously we must need to run a
lot more
a number of scenarios to achieve stable
and robust results
and typically in the risk environment
there is almost always a very short time
available to run those computations
trading risk um just applying these jp
morgan 125 times faster running the same
kind of idea
but this is interesting now is exchange
risk i'll just
skip forward and i'll come back to this
slide so we started taking our
technology into the low latency area
for high frequency trading um exactly
the same data flow technology as we use
everywhere else the compiler all the
tools the same
and applying this for high frequency
trading
where the turnaround time is in
microseconds between trades between the
trades and the exchange
and we we signed up a bunch of hedge
funds and they started doing it
and right down in the low level of our
compiler we write a message and so these
messages started turning up at the
exchange
maxella maxella maxella the next thing
we know we get a phone call from the
exchange
excuse me you're maxello why are we
getting all these messages from you with
with maxellar in
what's going on why and why are they
faster than everyone else so the next
thing we know
we're talking to the exchange and we've
now applied exactly the same technology
to re redesign and rework their
their top of book in other words
actually managing the flow of
prices and quantities and the order
matching process
the interesting thing about that is the
execution and rejection rate
what what feeds through from that then
is as you make the model faster
is this some kind of asymptotic behavior
and actually how do you measure the risk
at the limit
if these things are now being traded so
frequently and so quickly
how do you measure the risk how do you
capture that risk
so commonality of risk well we've spoken
a little bit about
geophysics financial modelling etc but
what's interesting is the data flow
based simulation scales across problems
i've just taken two
two examples here which do illustrate
the point
we can do black shells i mean okay black
shells people say
black shells isn't used well turns out
the exchanges use black shells if you
take the cme
they've got about 45 million live trades
of which about 30 million are options
and most of those are black shells so in
any one time period they're revaluing
those and looking at the risk in a very
large number of cases pretty much
all the time so we can do we can take a
thousand black shells and run them 10
million times
so that's basically 10 billion in 11.4
seconds
the ability to turn that round is
actually
changing the way that exchanges look at
risk and we're beginning to move into
that area
um as a very interesting byproduct and
at the other side so that's a simple
model
at the other side um a libor market
model which is basically
a multi-factor three-factor model um
based around a sort of monte carlo
simulation idea
and where we can run here a hundred
thousand uh bermuda and swaptions going
out ten years monthly exercise
um but on thirty thousand parts for
option we can run that in 15 seconds so
again pretty consistent speed up 30 30
the technology works very well across
the eye across both domains
so when order matters what we're really
interested in is
running scenarios an attempt to reduce
uncertainty most of our analysis is ad
hoc we need to think about key variables
most scenario analysis designed to
assume to find the worst case okay
mini max or maximin problem with looking
for the worst case is often
it isn't that instructive where you're
going to lose the money
is in the combinations of odd odd
factors that don't necessarily give you
the worst possible case
but because they occur more frequently
cumulatively you suffer larger losses
so what's our solution well and this is
kind of uh
more interesting one of the things we've
done in the last six months
since uh i arrived at maxella from
jpmorgan
is we've built our own finance library
from scratch
so we now have a complete library where
we have monte carlo
generalized pde solvers multi-normal
trees we can do generalized cash flow
generation we have interfaces in java c
matlab and excel
and we can look at risk in different
ways regulatory trading risk
but most importantly we've built an
engine that will do permutative and
combinatoric risk and span the space
very efficiently and we cover all the
major asset classes
the interesting thing about that is that
not only is it available
at a payment paying basis but it will
shortly be available
a stripped down and slightly simplified
version to experiment with will be
available to our university program
members
and as you can see you're on the list
and there is a fairly extensive
list of universities out there that are
going to be trying it we hope
thank you
no questions i'll sit down thank you i
didn't give away that easily
so i um
i i think that data flow
you can just tell me if i'm wrong and
what i'm thinking here but
you get um you get this throughput
oriented result
where you you're gonna produce a lot of
results but
for the first talk maybe they trickle
out somewhat slowly
and this in my mind stands a little bit
in contrast to my view of high frequency
trading which is
um as you said in high frequency trading
they they care so much about latency
and so you have this enormous throughput
but in my mind that implies a little bit
more
latency and so it doesn't
fully seem to match well on the high
frequency trading we're pushing through
much smaller amounts of data yeah so we
can if you think about it in terms of
kind of
parallelization we can push through lots
more data the data simpler
but we can push it through much more
quickly
you can add to that a little bit
so it's not the the data flow technology
that
reduces latency it's the fact that you
have a network card
right and then you have a microprocessor
here
there's some network you need to go
through the network card
do your figuring out with the messages
get it across interrupt the processor
do some computation and go back here
while what we're doing is you're saying
there's one chip there's a cable coming
through you have the network on the
other side the message goes through
that's right there everything is right
in there on the cable so you put the tcp
engine and the whole computation
on there in a loop move some stages
and type it back out so you save
yourself there
so you could do the same with any
network enabled fpga
um you could yes it just hardened the
program
um sort of a philosophical question
maybe more
for for you but like it
recently uh a lot of if
people are talking about exoscale and
the problem for the exascale
um is energy they
say oh if we did the sexa scale it would
you know require the
five nuclear power plants or whatever it
takes to run the accessible
computer and so so i guess
is it you got into this a little bit but
if you minimize energy do you minimize
your compute time or is the reverse
true or or is the real problem just
minimizing the cost of doing this
period like i mean dollar cost and
have you done some kind of look you know
you say this is 30 cpus but did you
calculate the you know the energy per
off
so to speak of this computation um the
the energy preparation is is the real
reason
not to use this technology because it's
a meaningless measure that can be used
to
to justify uh using very very high speed
operations
without having the data there i mean
doesn't it doesn't mean energy drop on
like a micro scale i just
system energy so what we are doing is we
are measuring
at the socket right so we put the
measure at the socket
and we say there's a certain computation
that takes one hour
right takes one hour and it takes this
amount of
watts during that one hour yes and we
are faster and lower power
and because of that lower energy so
how much well the total the
multiplication of these is between 20
and 50.
so if you're three times
faster you can be seven times lower
power if you are
five times faster you're four times
lower power so it kind of multiplies out
that way so you can slice it
any way you want but you can take a 20
hour computation and do it in one hour
or you can take something that requires
uh
a megawatt and uh divides that by by
roughly 20 maybe
with some inefficiencies there maybe
divide by 18. i guess
it's not i i'm i'm done after this for
for the sake of your question but i
guess the conjecture is
if you if you really minimize energy
would you also minimize
the computation time or are the there's
a trade-off
it's a trade-off it's like there is
there is no free lunch
you have you have the whole thing and
you can have more of this so you can
have more of that and you can trade one
to the other but you cannot have both
right
so you're trading off advantage on one
side with advantage on the other side
to get back to your question about
exascale exascale is a very interesting
case
in that really
it cannot be done and just recently it
was announced that the exascale
deadline has been moved from 2020 to
28 even though the department of energy
did have
a proposal that one company wrote
that showed clearly that they could have
exoskilled computing by 2018
and so computational speed and power
consumption is being touted is the most
important thing
but at the end of the day there's a lot
of other considerations
that are coming in place when when
excess scale is being discussed and then
the technologies are being evaluated so
so i wouldn't necessarily say that that
cost or power or compute speed are the
number one issues in exascale
it's a lot of it lies with legacy codes
and uh with structures that are in place
to deal with these legacy codes
and uh what these exoskill machines need
to be used for afterwards
so that's
i think there have been a lot of recent
developments to push up the performance
of some of the fpgas
in for example the acronic stuff and
some of that is
kind of profound uh under the hood but
uh
in general at least it's my experience
that these things tend to have wrappers
so that they very much look like legacy
stuff um
so uh it does does that imply that in
fact if you
got access to uh the the internals
you'd be able to derive better
efficiency
um yes so so we have we have done a
rough study
in that if we were to make our own chip
we could be roughly
five to ten times faster but uh
that would also come at a very large
cost it would require a very large
amount of volume
and hpc as a whole does not actually
justify
making a chip because as a whole the
whole market of high performance
computing is not large enough to to do
that today
so so that's kind of the chicken and egg
problem with with these things so we are
stuck with
prototyping them uh which still seems to
be
good enough on some as well
does that answer there yeah that answers
if there's time i'll ask one more
which is um there seems to be a lot of
good activity in the drug discovery
scene that is very much akin to this
um is that on your problem list uh yes
yes we do we do look at
not just drug discovery but also the
application of drugs to particular
patients so drug discovery is one thing
that is
uh touted a lot but even more
interesting from a patient perspective
is given that that you have a certain
problem
which of all of these drugs that are out
there would be optimal given your
genetic sequence
given your particular history and given
all kind of samples that you can take
from from that patient
and so that is a computationally immense
problem
that is very very core to the idea of
personalized medicine
trying to say what is the optimal
treatment not for the class of
patients that have certain
characteristics but for that one
particular patient in that particular
set of cells that he may have with with
their genetic mutations or whatever
so yes we are looking at these things
extensively
you i think you talked about what kind
of problems
these techniques are good for are there
what are the problems that they're not
good for
oh um i guess my
my quick question would my quick answer
would be
problems that that are simple that are
not real problems things that compute in
one second things that have no data or
representation associated with them
and then generally things that run very
nicely and easily on microprocessors
without
any need to to do them any better so
these are kind of the
yeah it's just one classification of
that second one that you said
that you know abstraction that you could
you know like a
a type of problem but uh i guess
i mean you can think of it as a
technology that is really excellent at
doing things
that you cannot do with any of the other
technologies because it requires more
effort
it is always optimal to spend less
effort so if you can spend less effort
it's better to use something else
if you cannot use something else then
here is an opportunity
to do something that goes beyond a
certain
activity given a power envelope given
the spacer
i mean i know of one problem which is
simulating gates and
it's kind of it's in this category of
it's
it's time it takes a lot of time it
takes a lot of resources but people seem
to just
throw their hands up when they want to
do some parallelism on it
i mean i'm just trying to think of an
example in response to you am i
like well that's eda and there's more
money and floss than there's an eda
i mean maybe that's the issue
could be the market or something yeah
no it doesn't justify the research and
development does it
um we have we have certainly students in
in the university program who are
looking at that
so we want to do some gates with dfe
yeah some very cheap verification
yeah yeah very cool yeah yeah so so
there are people looking at this it's
just not a very
high uh energy activity right now for us
but you know
okay cool thank you
you